welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
qualitative biased personal and
speculative remarks on digitization
digitalization and digital
transformation presented by Shawn
Maguire GSK associate fellow comparative
and translational Sciences veterinarian
GlaxoSmithKline
my name is Xavier tears and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your question to be email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. McGuire I went
out during the presentation over to him
thanks very much for that and I'd like
to thank the lab roots folks for
bringing me back to this 2019
presentation as I get started just want
to mention that occasionally in person
and also over video I am someone who
will stutter here and there and and and
so if you hear that it's not due to the
streaming or buffering quality of your
connection so as mentioned my name is
Shawn Maguire these are some other
Shawn McGuire's that are slightly more
famous and photogenic that I but just so
there's no confusion a at this point is
somewhat standard a disclaimer that I'll
give all views opinions future looking
statements suppositions and errors are
mine and not those of GSK anything
really insightful I say was likely
influenced by my colleagues and the
herbs and grammar or spelling or not the
fault of the Philadelphia public schools
so you know this is me in my current
role at GSK and before any of you choose
to invest the next 15 minutes or so of
your time I want to be clear about what
this presentation is not and so I'm not
going to be digging into you know a
wonderful data set from some you know
fresh out of statistics research that I
just completed unfortunately I'm not
gonna be able to lay out of the clear
path on how to integrate some of this
nascent technology into our preclinical
studies and also not going to really
dive into any specific technologies I'll
be raising some broad questions and
probably not a whole lot of answers
around this topic but what I will be
covering is a collection of my opinions
questions and other assorted thoughts
about the intersection of these
developing technologies and preclinical
studies with a primary focus on the on
the discovery space within the realm of
drug discovery and so as a way of
starting
I wanted to highlight what I think about
when we talk about this topic of
digitization and so this is this is
borrowed from the clinical realm and
actually throughout this presentation
I'm going to highlight some things that
I have that I've become familiar with in
the clinical space and and so it's
really about using some of these new
technologies both to both to innovate
right to do things in a way that we have
not done them before as well as to
actually run effective preclinical
studies and some of the advantages of
these digital technologies are really
around a increase both in statistical
power and sensitivity right we are
talking about technologies that allow us
to do very frequent data collection and
to collect things other that we haven't
collected before or ways that are much
less invasive to the animal and are
often much less resource-intensive from
the perspective of the researcher so you
know when we say digital endpoints I
found this definition helpful helpful to
me right so these are a way of
collecting patient outcomes or you know
in in our setting to get a better sense
of what's going on in the animal in a
continuous or semi continuous way and
this will enable the possibility of
these digital employ
I'm right so it so we would move from
making a cage side observation to be
able to look at a a real-time output of
these digital digital technology
measures and so it's it's certainly
happening and it's happening both in the
clinical and the preclinical space I
just want to highlight this this report
[Music]
excuse me
all right so looking at patients with
parkinson's disease or Huntington's
disease and they were able to collect
data in in such a way where they're not
really having to interrupt the patient's
normal daily routine but you know to
start to be able to pick things like
differences in sleep pattern in a much
more in a much more specific and likely
meaningful way than asking a patient you
know how have you been sleeping this
this information as well as other
information that I use in this talk
comes from a recommendation called
[Music]
developing technology derived novel
endpoints for use in clinical trials and
that's an NIH and academic and Industry
collaborative effort and so specifically
that's called the clinical trials
transformation initiative and they
highlight what they see as some of the
benefits of these technology derived
endpoints and as we take a look at them
I think that many of us in the
preclinical space can
see how some of these are directly
applicable to the work in the studies
that we do and that even those that are
not directly applicable have some have
some parallel have some parallel as well
as I think about trying to bring these
technologies into our preclinical
studies I find it important for me to
you know keep the end goal in mind that
that the the truly valuable preclinical
studies are those that are the most
translationally relevant and I do think
that many of these many of these digital
technologies that were talking about and
are being developed we have an
opportunity to line up very well what
happens in the preclinical setting and
the clinical setting so I think there is
a tremendous opportunity for
improvements and how we best to
understand our preclinical efforts and
how we care and use and and how we care
and use animals for this important
effort the developing and possible
impacts on animals welfare study design
intervention analysis interpretation and
translational relevance are critical and
as a community I think we have an
obligation to pursue well these
technologies allow us to do a better job
of digitizing routine preclinical
patient care subject management how we
observe our animals and if we started to
do that what would be the follow-on
improvements or standing things have
been even higher level are what's going
on in particularly in a particular room
in the facility as a whole and how will
seeing trends over time improve both
what we do in a study sense as well as
the care and welfare sets
you know I think the answer to the
question are absolutely and there are
really well done publications and
posters out there to support that I
think the challenge is how do we find
the way to implement and integrate these
technologies which will allow us to
evolve them in a manner that supports
scientific discovery and proves animal
care and welfare in thinking about some
of the differences between human
clinical studies and our preclinical
efforts it is important to note that
clinical studies use the infrastructure
that's built around the provision of
medicine to the patient as an
oversimplification especially in the
discovery setting we have a minimalist
infrastructure onto which we add in a
mostly targeted way specific technology
to provide observations markers or
endpoints if we want a more robust
similar data set in the preclinical
space that a more robust infrastructure
is required right and and so patients in
clinical trials are still first treated
as patients in a much more holistic way
where many things are looked at in
addition to the study goals we have an
opportunity to do something similar with
much of the digital technology that
we're talking about for our preclinical
species so when do we as individual
researchers or as part of a larger
effort decide to invest budget into
these technologies and how do we handle
the challenge of its the technology
doesn't do everything that I wanted to
right now versus the fact that much of
this technology allows us to do things
that we have not ever done before you
know how do we assess the promised value
and impact that a technology could
should might provide
against actual investment costs and
those costs include time pupil resource
and opportunity costs how do we assess
cost of implementation against costs of
the status quo right if we're if these
technologies will allow us to do to do
more effective and efficient preclinical
studies and we're not investing in them
now you know there can be certainly an
imagined cost to just staying with the
status quo
all right so I already showed this slide
earlier and right you know again I think
there's a great amount of overlap
between what they're talking about in
the clinical space and what we're
talking about in the preclinical space
one of the great advantages of these
developing digital technologies is a
continuous or semi continuous monitoring
and data recording and that they move
from they can move us from qualitative
assessments to quantitative or
semi-quantitative some of these
technologies will allow us to move from
infrequent point in time and subjective
observations to more frequent and
qualitative observations an advantageous
aspect of many of these technologies is
around reproducibility reducing bias and
possibly even on the documentation side
of things and I suggest that all of
these will prove the value of research
as well as the care use of animals as I
look at the comparisons between what is
currently available in the human
clinical space including patient
customer consumer owned technology say
such as smartwatches and phones and even
extending that look into the era
medicine clinical space and the types of
technologies that are available
to pet owners for their pets and what we
are routinely using and what's available
in the preclinical preclinical discovery
to space I feel that we are somewhat
lagging behind in our adaptation of
these technologies as well as the
current state of what's available and to
be clear these comments should not be
taken as a way of minimizing the great
efforts investment and impact colleagues
and companies that are actively working
in this space because in fact without
them we would not be having this
conversation at all and so why the lag
so I I wonder if it has to do with the
infrastructure issue that I mentioned
before I wonder if it's been hindered by
certainly in the drug discovery setting
are sometimes reticence about how we
share data the challenge in trying to
work out what the perceived cost a
benefit is and that when it comes down
to actually spending on the technology
whose budget should that outlay come
from I think there's also an appropriate
concern about the regulatory space and
how some of the regulatory agencies may
handle or may respond to some
preclinical studies that I use this data
and then certainly standards and
practices need to be need to be
developed and with most of the remaining
slides I just want to highlight some
clinical current clinical applications
and and and how they may be relevant to
the work that we do and
and so currently in the in the
preclinical space looking at respiratory
rate is a challenge and it's with
without some of this digital technology
it is difficult to do in a continuous or
semi continuous way what this human
paper points out is that if you can
track respiratory rate variability that
as a prognostic factor that it has a
great value and so there are certainly
preclinical models that we use where if
we have the ability to measure
respiratory rate and can therefore look
at respiratory rate variability we have
an opportunity to to to develop a
measure like that as an endpoint and and
which would allow a different type of
intervention in a animal study again
another paper looking at the at the
value of respiratory rate this one in
patients with with pneumonia and so what
they found is that respiratory rate is
an independent risk marker for in
hospital mortality and and so I I
suggest that you know this this provides
some insight again may be particularly
relevant to some preclinical respiratory
focused models but the that there is an
opportunity as we can measure more in
different things to establish truly
predictive as well as meaningful
influence
I thought this was a interesting paper
from the perspective of they highlight
the fact that in human setting
respiratory rate is often measured
manually and discontinuously by Counting
of chest wall right and certainly in the
veterinary medicine space we do that as
well in in many of our preclinical
species it is a challenge to do I I
can't count that fast for say a mouse
that is respiring
very quickly and getting getting a
respiratory rate from some of our other
species in a setting where they're
freely moving is certainly a challenge
but what they didn't in this paper is
they they they took a measure a
respiratory rate and found a way to
measure it in a less invasive way right
the patient isn't even aware that um
that it's being that the data is being
collected it counts it in a less bias
and more objective way and in a
continuous or semi continuous way and
all of that allows for allow for
respiratory rate to be used as a way of
highlighting which patients are at
greatest worst and which patients
patients require intervention we think
about it in the preclinical space and
this may actually provide a more
sensitive measure than some of our
currently used workers of disease
so this is a paper that highlights the
value of a wearable to collect a number
of things including rate and I believe
oxygen saturation and from those a
number of other parameters can also be
calculated and the big gone ahead and
done the comparison with the wearable
measure and the gold standards and just
to point out that while we have
challenges in the preclinical space
right it's very difficult to put a to
put some of the wearables on to animals
and ask them to please leave them alone
but the technology is there and I think
the challenge is really to us on us as
to how we implement them one more
example and so this is an example of the
vest that COPD patients can wear again
around the value of a respiratory rate
and you know working towards ways of
measurement that have as minimal of an
impact on the patient as possible which
again I think is something that we
strive to do in our preclinical setting
as well right when we think about
respiratory rate you know there are
there are probably inherent changes when
we start to manipulate the animal and so
if we have a if we have a remote and
continuous way of doing this our
opportunity to collect valuable data
goes up significant link
a next to final point that I'll make is
that as we begin to integrate some of
these digital technologies the
thoughtful application of artificial
intelligence and deep learning to make
sense of these larger by orders of
magnitude datasets will be critical in
order to gain the most impact on drug
discovery and improving our caring use
of preclinical species a caveat is that
any useful algorithm is based on data
sets that have already been collected
and so we will still need human
intelligence and intervention as new
data or novel effects are observed and
with a much larger data set the
challenge of separating translatable and
relevant signal from noise takes on
greater importance
none of these digital none of these
digital measures markers or endpoints
should be looked at in isolation right
we need to use our use our increasing
understanding of fields like genomics
immunology and oncology just as a few
just as a few examples right we need to
apply those to the novel insights that
we gained which will hopefully allow us
to best understand which preclinical
findings are truly translatable truly
translatable to humans so this is
another slide that I've borrowed from
the C TTI and I think that they
highlight some important things to be
thinking about as we have the discussion
about which technology to integrate when
and you know one of the challenges that
that I see us as a community facing is
how do we move from from the small pilot
studies that are that are very actively
going on to really scaling up
with the possibility of creating you
know a significant change in in the
minimum that we get out of any
preclinical study and so with that I'll
leave you to ponder those points if
you'd like if you'd like the list of the
papers and websites that I've mentioned
shoot me an email and I'll happily
provide that I hope you enjoyed our
little chat and I hope you enjoyed the
rest of the conference thanks very much
thank you dr. McGuire for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019 as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon
goodbye